all right it looks like we're live
great so welcome to day two
thanks for joining us again today
we're going to talk about
a few things
so here's our agenda for today we're
going to talk about time
and clocks
lan port diagrams
network models
causality and
happens before
and state and events
and i'll explain what all this stuff
means and if we have time at the end
i'm going to do some announcements
before we jump into this any questions
left over from last time
oh i should probably start a lecture
stream for today shouldn't i
oh somebody else started one awesome
thank you
great okay
questions from last time
going once going twice oh yeah go ahead
sure
please
twitch.tv lindsay cooper
all right let me write that down here
yep you can find all this uh on zulip as
well
all right no other questions let's jump
in uh so
today um we're going to start by talking
about time
and clocks and so let me begin by asking
you a question
um
what do we use time for when you're
writing software what it or let me put
it a different way what do you use
clocks for
what are what are some things that you
use clocks for in the context of
developing software
scheduling okay so
what do we mean by scheduling
somebody has suggested scheduling
scheduling what
yeah assigning start and end times two
things
okay so this class
begins at 3 20 p.m pacific time
so we use clocks to say when something
will happen
right so that we all know to be here at
this time
so this class
starts at 3 20 pm
pt this is one
one thing we use time for we use it for
marking particular points in time
or what are some other examples of this
um you could say like
this item
in my browser cache
expires on april 1
at 8 pm pt
for example so these are marking
particular points in time
or this error message in the log file
has a timestamp
of whenever
it sounds like somebody needs to mute
themselves
all right so these are examples of
things that you could use clocks for
for marking points in time what else
what do we use
what else do we use clocks for other
than this
any thoughts
all right yeah that's very annoying let
me see if i can mute everybody
all right sorry about that
yeah so the person you just asked about
chat uh yeah we're using chat uh we're
using chat on zulu for everything
okay back to time
so um what else do we use clocks for
other than marking points in time
one other thing that we do is
durations or intervals of time
so this class is 95 minutes long
or this request will timeout
in five seconds
so you get the idea so a couple of
notions of
what we use clocks for marking points in
time
and then tracking durations or intervals
of time
so these are kind of fundamentally
different things and we can use
different kinds of clocks
to do both of these things so computers
have
a couple of different kinds of clocks
in particular they have both what are
called time of day clocks
and monotonic clocks
so time of day clock
is not so good for measuring things like
durations or intervals
so time of day quite simply tells you
what time of day it is
um
it can be synchronized between machines
using something like
ntp or network time protocol which you
can look up if you want to
and i say that it's not so good for
measuring durations or intervals of time
why would that be the case anyone know
too slow is the suggestion
so
i'm actually going to say that it's not
that but it's actually another reason
the reason why time of day clocks are
maybe not so great yeah so somebody just
said possible fluctuations good
so time of day clocks can actually jump
forward or backward
this is perhaps a little bit surprising
if you think that time is always going
to move forward in a straight line
but unfortunately uh
it doesn't or at least our ways of
measuring time with time of day clocks
don't give us that
so if you've never heard of the notion
of a leap second for example
um you might want to go look it up it's
kind of interesting and if you want to
read about a really fun
distributed systems bug look up the
cloudflare leap second bug from 2016.
they did a blog post about it let me
bring it up here
so this is a great blog post actually
this was published
on uh january 1st 2017 how and why the
leap second affected cloudflare dns
so i'm not going to go into all the
details here but this is fun to read if
you want to read about a really fun
distributed systems bug
that amounted to somebody using a time
of day clock
when they should have been using a
monotonic clock
so let's go back to talking about
monotonic clocks
a monotonic clock only goes forward
so a monotonic clock actually is pretty
good
for measuring things like durations or
intervals
but it's not so good for marking
particular points in time
why is that the case
well the trouble is that
a monotonic clock is only meaningful on
a particular machine
so you can try and experiment
right now so try this
in python
run your python interpreter and do
import time
and then call time dot
monotonic
somebody try this right now and tell me
what you get
okay so one person got
[Music]
13.965 something something something and
somebody else got
two three eight six six one
i'm actually a little bit surprised by
this one i'm surprised that it would be
such a low number
um all right so people are getting some
different things here
they're all different so why do we all
have different
monotonic clock values it's because the
value of the monotonic clock isn't
comparable
it's not it's not comparable between
different machines
so it's the absolute value of this
number is meaningless
in terms of trying to do comparisons
between machines
it's just a a number that so for example
in python i think it's the number of
milliseconds since you restarted your
machine
um so
not comparable between machines
so you shouldn't expect it to agree
so of these two kinds of clocks time of
day clocks and monotonic clocks
which do you think are useful in
implementing distributed systems well
we can try to figure it out
so
time of day clocks
and monotonic clocks are the two kinds
of physical clocks that we have
so we can make this little two by two
grid here
and then the things that we would want
to do with clocks are
measuring points in time
and then measuring intervals or
iterations
so what's good for what
so are time of day clocks good for
measuring intervals and durations
what did we just say
no they're not so good for that because
of what we just said
about how time of day clocks can jump
forward and backward and if you look at
that great um
sorry about this if you look at that
great cloudflare
blog post that i mentioned um you'll see
that
what happened was that somebody was
trying to use a time-of-day clock in a
setting where they really should have
been using a monotonic clock
and so a clock ended up going backward
at a time when the software wasn't
expecting it to because we expect
monotonic clocks to only move forward so
time of day clocks are really not so
good for intervals and durations
monotonic clocks are fine
okay what about measuring points in time
can you do that with monotonic clocks
nope yeah so
if we were trying to use monotonic
clocks to say what time class starts
that would be unhelpful right because
everybody has their own monotonic clock
okay should i be putting a happy face
here
for time of day clocks and points in
time
do we want to use time of day clocks for
marking points in time and distributed
systems
i would love it if i could put a happy
face in this square
unfortunately i kind of have to put a
face like that because as we're about to
see
time of day clocks are okay for
measuring points in time
but only okay
so monotonic clocks are great for
implementing distributed systems why
because we can use them to implement
timeouts
like we talked about last time and
timeouts are something that we often
need
but they're not so good for comparing
between machines
why are time of day clocks not
useful for points in time well
i think we can explain it very
straightforwardly
so let's say we have two machines
and let's say that they both
currently think that x is five and i'll
draw some lines here representing the
passage of time on these two machines
so let's say that m1 thinks that this is
3pm
now maybe m1 and m2 are synchronized
over ntp if that's the case then
their clocks are probably pretty close
to being in sync
but not necessarily perfectly in sync so
maybe m2 thinks that 3pm is right here
well
let's say that m1 sends m2 a message
to increment x so that increment let's
say takes place here and now x is 6.
let's say that these machines are
supposed to take a snapshot of what
they're doing at 3 pm
well m1 snapshot looks like this
m2's snapshot looks like this we go and
compare the snapshots later
on m2 snapshot says that x is 6.
why does it say that x is 6 because well
it says i got this message
before 3 pm from m1 that told me to
increment x so i did
meanwhile m1 is over here it's like that
never happened
and one didn't know about it so
depending on what happens during this
interval
we could get in a lot of trouble by
using time of day clocks
for marking points in time and
distributed systems
so the trouble is that the timestamps
don't agree with the order in which
these events actually occurred
and this could cause all kinds of
problems in real systems
even causing database rights to be
dropped and stuff like that so
time of day clocks aren't so useful for
measuring or marking points in time in a
distributed system
some systems do it anyway
so this column's looking pretty bad
right
we know monotonic clocks aren't good for
this purpose
and time of day clocks are merely okay
so somebody just asked in chat why is
3pm different for the two different
machines and time of day clocks well
it's because even if we're using
something to synchronize clocks like ntp
it can't necessarily be perfect
right so machines are going to disagree
now i want to push back on something
that somebody just said in chat which
mentioned time zone so this isn't
necessarily
this isn't about time zones uh all these
let's say all these machines are using
utc
so the the issue isn't time zones that's
certainly an issue with
uh distributed systems of humans who are
trying to rendezvous at a particular
time
but with these computers we can assume
they're they're all using utc
so time zones are not the issue here the
issue is that these machines clocks
aren't perfectly synchronized
and we cannot no matter what we do we
can't get them to be perfectly
synchronized
so really the issue here is that we're
trying to use physical clocks so both
time of day clocks and monotonic clocks
are
are what are known as physical clocks
and in this course
we're going to be talking about how to
throw this out and use a radically
different notion of a clock called a
logical clock
so we're not going to be measuring time
of day and we're not going to be
measuring
intervals of time either instead
we're only going to be measuring
the order of events
we'll be discussing this idea quite a
lot this quarter
so a fundamental question when talking
about ordering of events
is what event happened before another
event
so let's say that we have two events a
and b
and they could be anything at all maybe
there are rights to a database but they
could really be anything
and let's suppose that i know that event
a happened before event v
so let's introduce a little bit of
notation for this
we'll write a arrow b
and this is pronounced a happened before
b
okay if i know that a happened before b
how is it useful what can i do with that
information what do you think
by the way a minute ago somebody said uh
they were on twitch and they couldn't
hear the student talking that's actually
intentional
so i'm not streaming our zoom meeting to
twitch
i'm just streaming myself to twitch and
that's on purpose because
i don't want to compromise anybody's
privacy by putting their video and audio
on the twitch stream so the twitch
stream is just me
all right so yeah so what does it tell
me
that a happened before b in particular
what does that tell me about
what caused what or what might have
caused what
foreign
good okay somebody just said a could
have caused b
do we know for sure that a caused b no
absolutely not but it might have
and somebody else just added
b could not have caused a
good
so this notion of causality in this case
that a
could have caused b but b could not have
caused a is very important in
distributed systems
why why is this so important how does it
help us
what do you think
yeah so somebody said we know the
sequence of events yeah
so how is that useful information well
one way it could help us is debugging
right
let's say that i'm looking at my
distributed system and i have some sort
of bug
like one machine thinks that x is five
and the other machine
thinks that x is six well it's helpful
at that point to be able to look back at
all the events that have occurred
and try to figure out what may have
caused x to be
six or what caused x to be five so
in particular like if we look back at
this picture here
these time of day clocks weren't all
that helpful to us right
but if we can figure out
that it was this increment here that
caused
x to be six over here and we know that
that
happened before this
in the sense of this logical uh in the
sense of logical clocks in the sense of
the happen
happened before relation then that's
useful information it helps us
understand what happens
so this notion of happens before isn't
going to answer all our questions but it
will at least
let us rule out some things that
definitely didn't cause a bug
it's also useful for designing systems
in the first place even before you get
to the stage of debugging because
if you can design a system in such a way
that if you
know that an event a happened before an
event b
then you can design the system in a way
that will never allow users to
see event b before they see event a and
we'll talk more about that soon
okay so this is one of the most
important concepts in this course
and what we want to do is because time
is going to be so important and the
order of events is going to be so
important
we want to introduce a sort of visual
language for talking about what happened
before what
and if you think about those figures
that i was drawing in lecture last time
that looked like this
the trouble with that kind of a picture
is that coming back and looking at it
now
i can't tell what happened before what
right i don't know which of these
messages came first and which of these
messages came second
so instead of drawing pictures that way
we're going to introduce a new sort of
visual language
for talking about the execution of a
distributed system that will let us talk
about time
so for that we're going to use what are
known as lan port diagrams
these are also known as space time
diagrams
if you want an especially cool sounding
name
in fact we already did see a lan port
diagram a second ago when i was drawing
arrows
so this visual language for talking
about time is very simple
the idea is that a process
is a line
it's got a discrete beginning and it
goes on forever
so this is a process
events are dots on the line
let's say that this process represents
machine one
so we'll give some names to these events
here
if i pick two dots on this line let's
say x and z
could x have caused z
sure yeah
could z have caused x
no did x cause z
well maybe we don't know
so given any event all i have to do
to find its cause or its possible cause
is to look before it
on the line if i want to know why an
event happened
something above it was responsible
so in this case y also happened before z
and x happened before y
but it actually gets more complicated
than this right because we don't have
just one machine we have multiple
machines in a distributed system
and because these machines don't share
memory
and can't read each other's minds
they have to communicate with each other
by sending and receiving messages so
let's add a couple of more machines to
this picture
so now we have three machines and let's
add some messages
so maybe m2 has a message that it sends
to m1
maybe m1 sends one to m0
maybe m1 also sends one to m2
and message sends and receives are also
events
in fact they're very important kinds of
events so given this picture as a guide
let's try to come up with a general
definition for when
one event happens before another
we already talked about part of it right
so
we know that x happened before z
because they're here on the same process
line and x is higher up on the line so
that's the first part of the definition
so given any two events
we say a happened before b
if any of the following are true
so if a and b occur on the same process
line
there's more anybody want to try to
guess the next part of the definition
i'll give you a hint it has to do with
these messages being sent and received
hmm somebody just asked in chat so do
the different processes have different
space times
i'm not exactly sure i know what that
means
well
let's see let's call this event p right
here
let's call this one s
so if p is when you send a message an s
is when you receive a message
receiving a message has to come
after it was sent right it couldn't
possibly be before
has to be after so
we can also say a happened before b if
a is a send event
and b is the corresponding receive event
so p happens before s here
there's one more part to this definition
can anybody guess what it might be
i'll give you a hint
what if we want to talk about a happens
before relationship between
p and z can we do that
transitivity good
so the last part of the definition is
let's say that we have some other event
call it c
so if a happens before c some event c
and c happens before b
then we can say that a happens before b
what this last part of the definition
does
is it makes this happens before a
relation transitive
what that means is that i can put
together
these first two parts of the definition
so for example
we know that p happens before s because
p is a message send and s is the
corresponding receive
we know that s happens before y because
they're on the same process
line here with s first
we know that y happens before z because
again they're on the same process line
and plugging all those all together
using this uh this transitivity property
we can see that p happens before z
so that's the definition of the happens
before relation
later on we're going to talk about how
to compute what's in the happens before
relations so that if we have some event
then we can figure out what events
happened before it
and the cause of that event must be
somewhere
in the events that happened before
so somebody just asked uh can event an
event be a send event or a receive event
or both
so uh great question so here we have
some events that are
like this one here p for example is a
send event and s is a receive event
these ones here like x y and z these are
neither so i would call these internal
events
so those are still events but they're
neither sends nor receives they're
events that are internal to this
this process m1
and an event couldn't be both ascend and
receive it would have to be
one or the other
okay so now that we've introduced this
notion of happens before
uh let's uh let me let me show you a
classic lanport diagram
it involves some strong language so
let's say that we have alice
bob and carol
let's say that alice sends a message
to bob and carol
and alice says bob smells
all right well bob gets this message
right and he can't let this stand so bob
has to respond to this
so bob responds with
you alice
now the question here is what does carol
think
right carol is receiving this very rude
message from bob
what do you think carol is thinking at
this point
carol has not yet seen this earlier
message that prompted the comment from
from alice or for the comment from bob
rather
so now carol is probably a little bit
confused at this point
this is what's known as a causal
anomaly
generally speaking anomalies are things
that make you go huh
and carol is certainly saying huh in
this case
so we're going to talk about how we can
use the concept of happens before
to rule out anomalies like this by the
way
why did this bob smells message take so
long to get to carol over here
sure alice could be far away it could be
any number of reasons which we talked
about last time a message could just be
slow
right recall that we talked about how a
distributed system
uh experiences unbounded latency
and if we're not careful in designing
our systems then latency will lead to
bugs actually
it's probably going to lead to bugs no
matter what um
but certain problems are going to be
going to be solvable in this setting of
unbounded latency
let me back up a second uh somebody
asked another question uh
about the previous drawing i did
um
yeah so somebody thought y was both a
send and receive event no it's actually
neither it's an internal event
so p is ascend s is a receive x y z are
in internal events
uh these ones i didn't give names to but
these two are sends and these two are
our receives
feel free to ask more questions if if uh
that didn't make sense
okay so
moving on from there
this concept of unbounded latency is
going to cause a lot of problems
if we're not careful and that brings us
to talking about network models it would
really
make life easy we talked about this a
little bit last time
if we knew that there was some fixed
amount of time that it took
for a message to get from alice to its
intended recipient
right if we had that kind of a network
then it would be called a synchronous
network
and synchronous networks do exist but
they aren't the kind that we're going to
be spending most of our time on
in this course i'm going to define it
anyway just so that we have a definition
but then we won't spend much more time
talking about it so to be precise a
synchronous network
is one where
there exists
uh and some n
where n is in units of time
such that
no message
takes longer
than n
units of time to be delivered
that's what a synchronous network is
let us speak no more
of the synchronous network model
what other network model is there well
an asynchronous network
what do you think an asynchronous
network is
unbounded latency good yeah so
specifically an asynchronous network
is one where
there exists no n
such that no message takes longer
than n units of time
you get the idea it's the same as above
so we're going to be spending most of
our time in this class talking about
the asynchronous network model
not because it makes our life easy
because it certainly doesn't
but because this is the more realistic
approach so
if i were going to ask you to implement
a protocol
and you need to pick a network model to
work with
what network model are you going to pick
to make sure that the protocol that
you're implementing is
is robust and i'm using this word
protocol by that i just mean
a set of rules that computers use to
communicate with each other
so if you want to make sure to implement
a robust protocol you're going to pick
the network model that is the least
forgiving
right because you want to try to make
sure that your protocol works even under
the worst conditions
so you're going to pick the asynchronous
network model
and so in this course we're going to be
spending most of our time focusing on
the asynchronous network model and not
making any assumptions
about uh this sort of maximum latency of
messages that we would get in in a
synchronous network
there's also something if you want to go
look it up on your own there are so
called partially synchronous networks
and there are different ways of defining
partially synchronous but one way of
defining a partially synchronous network
is
there is some n such that no message
takes longer than n units of time to be
delivered
but you don't know what it is you don't
get to know in advance what that n
is so that turns out to be a useful
notion especially for
for certain kinds of verification tasks
but we're not going to be talking about
that very much in this course it's
something that you can check out on your
own if you're interested
all right so
i want to pause at this point and take
our 10-minute break
any questions before we have a pause
all right one person asked you know why
why are we not speaking about the
synchronous network model yeah i know
wouldn't it make our lives nice if we
could
um unfortunately you know the internet
should not be thought of as a
synchronous network
so well we want things to work on the
internet right
so we have to use and the thing is
in practice no sometimes you can pick an
n
that makes sense most of the time but if
you want to implement protocols that are
always going to
do what you say they do then it makes a
lot of sense
to use this less forgiving network model
that will force you to design the
protocol
in such a way that it will be robust
to this unbounded message latency
all right with that let's take our break
and i'll put up today's quiz question
all right i've posted the link in chat
go ahead and take a stab at the quiz and
i'll start our 10 minute timer
and be sure to stretch your legs and get
your eyes away from the screen for a
minute
and i'll see you back here at 4 21.
you
all right the 10 minute timer just went
off from me
looks like just about everybody answered
the quiz so that's great
let's get back to the lecture
okay so the quiz question was about the
happens before relation uh let's recap
the definition of the happens before
relation
so we'll talk about two events a and b
so if a
and b occur on the same process
with a before b
then a happens before b so that would be
like this right
if you have a lan port diagram
consisting of a process
and you have a couple of dots on that
process line
and a is higher up than b then
you know that a happens before b by the
way the way that i always draw landmark
diagrams is to have time going down
like this but you'll see people do it in
all kinds of different styles sometimes
you'll have
time going this way or that way or even
up
but this is how i always draw them every
time i draw a lan port diagram in this
class
time will be moving downward
so that's the first part of the
definition
somebody tell me what the second part is
that's right those are two internal
events on this particular line
so sending and receiving are things that
happen between
processes right so if you have something
like this
if this is a and this is b
so a is ascend event and b is the
corresponding receive event
then we know a happens before b
and then what's the last part of the
definition
i think there's a little bit of
confusion in the chat right now because
when people were saying
a is ascend event and b is a receive
event i think they were giving the
second
piece of the definition here they
weren't talking about this a and b up
here
right so the last part is if you have
some other event c
such that you know a happens before c
and c happens before b
then you know that a happens before b
and that's what lets you tie together
all this with transitivity so you could
have something like this
where you could have a happening before
c because a is ascend and c
is a receive and then maybe b is this
other event down here
well then we know that a happens before
b also because we can put together
these two happens before relationships
between a and c
and c and b to get that a happens before
b
so let's go back to the picture that
uh that we were showing a minute ago
that had a bunch more events on it
so if i pick two events here um
let's say let me let me actually give
some more names to some of these events
um so what names have i not used here
yet let's have this be
q r
so we already talked about some pairs of
events and how they're related right we
talked about how x and z
are related so we talked about that we
talked about how y and z are related
x and y p and s
how about r and z
are those events related
by the happens before relation
no they're not so it's not the case that
r happens before z and it's also not the
case that z
happens before r so
sorry r here so we can write a little uh
not happens before like this
when this is the case for two events
we say that they're concurrent
and there are several more pairs of
concurrent events in this picture what's
another pair of concurrent events
p and x good yeah so we can't say
anything
about whether p happened we can't say
that p happened before x
we can't say that x happened before p
because they're on different machines
right and these machines don't share a
clock
so even though we've drawn this picture
like timed
going downward like this and you might
think that you know
x is a little bit below p right if we're
looking at this
horizontal axis like this
that doesn't actually mean anything in
terms of determining what happened
before what
because there isn't some common notion
of time across all these processes
so we cannot say that p happened before
x nor can we say that x happened before
p
they're concurrent
so we'll talk about this a little bit
more next time and we'll
we'll get into a little bit of the math
um
but uh but that's the happens before
relation
and this is going to be something we
spend a lot of time talking about in
this course
so there's something else on my agenda
uh which was to talk about state and
events
so
oh before i do that somebody just asked
somebody asked so these are three
monotonic clocks
interesting questions so we talked about
monotonic clocks and we talked about
time of day clocks but those are both
physical clocks
so when you call time dot monotonic for
example in python um
that's telling you something like the
number of milliseconds since you last
restarted your machine
but um it's still the notion of physical
time it's still a notion of
of milliseconds or seconds so
that's not the notion of time that we're
dealing with here we're just dealing
with
uh this this happens before relationship
between events
and starting next time we're going to be
working with uh
we're going to be defining a mechanism
that's a logical clock that will that
will let you
um determine
uh that happens before ordering of
events so
what i've done here is given a
definition for this happens before
relation
but i haven't yet told you how to
compute the happens before relation if i
give you a whole bunch of events
i haven't told you how to compute what
happens before what and so next time
we're going to be talking about logical
clocks and that will let you actually
determine how to how to figure out what
happens before what
okay so let's talk about state and
events
so we already kind of talked about
events right like a dot on a lan port
diagram is an event but what about state
we haven't talked about that yet so
what is a state like when you when you
study
computer architecture for example
what do you think would be included if i
talk about the state of a machine
we'll think back to the picture that i
drew on day one of class right
where we had m1 asking them two
questions
well we said m2 knew that x was five
right
oh good so people are asking someone are
giving some good answers here so
what the question was what is a state
what do we say what do we mean when we
talk about the state of a machine
um so this right here saying that x is
five is part of state right it's
it's something that this machine knows
so state could be like
the contents of memory or the contents
of registers and
and so on but in this world
of distributed systems where we just
have events that are occurring on a
timeline like this how do we talk about
state
well i am going to argue that
a dot on these diagrams is
also a state
so maybe you know this is m2
and it knows that x is 5. well how did
it know that x was 5.
i'm going to argue that whatever the
contents of this computer's memory are
at a certain point
it's completely determined by all the
events that have happened
up until then so
you know maybe there's another event
here that happens to be a message being
received right
maybe m1 is over here
um maybe m1 sent a message that said
to set x to five
in this case x already was five
but maybe it sends another message later
so we'll give some names to these events
let's say these are events a b and c
all of these these messages here i don't
know what a was maybe it was some sort
of an internal event it doesn't really
matter
but the point is the contents of this
machine's memory in this case the value
of x
is completely determined by all of the
events
that have happened up until then so
we can always work out what state we're
in
by looking back at the sequence of
events
so if we were to lasso up all these
events that have occurred on m2
and kind of look at them out of context
um
we didn't say what a was um maybe a was
uh maybe a was
uh it doesn't really matter um
so a i don't know what it was b was
set x to five c
was set x to six
we can look at those events in some sort
of a log
and replay them and at the end
we'll know that x was six right so
we can always work out what state we're
supposed to be in
by looking back at the events that have
happened
can we do the reverse like if i just
told you this
if i just told you that x was 6 do you
know the sequence of events that led to
that
no because there are a lot of different
ways that you could have gotten to this
state where x is six
and we have limited resources right so
in practice
we probably aren't going to keep a log
of everything that happened ever
so with the limited resources that we
have no
we probably cannot reconstruct all the
events that have ever occurred
just given the state that we're in now
however if we have the events we can get
the state so
it's kind of nice to be able to keep
that log around for as long as we can
right
assuming that you have enough resources
to be able to do so
because if you need the state you can
always get it from that sequence of
events
but if all you have is the state then
you can't reconstruct the sequence of
events from that
so somebody just asked uh do events
cause changes in state well yeah
so these are events that indeed cause
this event happened to cause a change in
state
now some events wouldn't cause a change
in state right if you receive a message
but all it does is ask the value of x
then that doesn't
give you a state change although
if you wanted to you could log that
event right and then it would be a
change in the state of the log i suppose
but
um but some events are going to do a
meaning are going to make a meaningful
state change
uh and others aren't so um
and that kind of gets back to this
concept of uh when you know what the
state is
you don't know what sequence of events
might have led to that if we're in this
state where x is six
then we don't know if the sequence of
events that have happened would be
were like you know one process sending
us a message that set the state to six
and then a thousand messages being
received that were just queries about
the value
of x or if there were
a sequence of events that were
alternating setting x to six and five
and six and five and six and five and
then
at the moment that we happened to look
at the state it happened to be six so we
can't tell what that history is just
from looking at the state in the given
moment
yeah so in the question just asked in
chat was is the only thing in the state
is the value of x
um for this one yeah i mean that's all
that's all the state that i'm talking
about here
if this were a key value store then you
would probably have
more key value pairs that you cared
about right you might also have a value
of y and so forth
when we draw these lanport diagrams so
if we were being really really
disciplined about how we
how we drew lanport diagrams they would
consist only
of processes and events and messages and
that would be it
but some of the time we're going to
cheat
and we're going to write down little
pieces of state like this
like this right this piece of state here
is something that i wrote down
it's kind of extraneous to the rest of
this lanport diagram but i'm going to
argue that it's sort of a shorthand
for events that could have occurred
either because somebody else sent us
messages earlier
some either some series of events
occurred that led to x being
uh set to five whether because they were
messages that receive
or some sort of eternal events occurred
that said x to five maybe there was an
internal event when m2 started up
that said have xb5 from the beginning
so we're going to cheat a little bit in
some of the lanport diagrams that we
draw in this course by writing little
pieces of state like this
but i just want you to know that if you
wanted to
you could boil everything down to events
and you could write down all of the
individual events that led to that state
so this is cheating but i think it's a
legal way of cheating because if you
wanted to
you could fill in the events that led to
that state
all right so somebody just asked a good
question in chat they said would we be
able to
reconstruct the series of events that
led to the current state if we knew that
one and only one event could lead to
that state well okay so
yeah i suppose so um but also
there could have been events that never
had any effect right
so like we said if in this case if there
were some queries in the value of x
um then those might never have been
logged right
so do you care that those occurred
well maybe you don't care if all you
care about is what the value of x is but
maybe you care about
the queries that are occurring if you
want to know how heavy the load on m2
is so you know whether you need another
machine
so i guess it depends you know what
context you're in and
and what kind of events you care about
all right i think that's it for course
content for today
i want to spend the rest of the time
talking about some uh
course business and announcements so
let's switch to
the course overview for a minute
this is something that i am kind of sad
to talk about my least favorite topic
academic integrity so actually i'm going
to talk about academic integrity on
assignments first
because this is kind of the more
immediately relevant topic because our
first assignment comes out tomorrow
yep so in this course
we want you to discuss your to discuss
your work with others right
but everything that you turn in has to
be your own work
so if it's assignment one it has to be
your own independent work
assignment one is not done in a team
if it's assignments two through four
then it has to be the independent work
of your team
if you do otherwise you will fail the
course
so you can ask for advice from the tas
and tutors and me
and your classmates but you can't copy
from anyone else
so we're asking you to document the
process
that you use to carry out the
assignments as follows
and this is going to be covered in the
assignment description too and also this
is all on the course website so you can
go read it but
here's what we're asking you to do when
you turn in your assignment there is
going to be a readme file that we ask
you to to include
and you have to include the following
sections um
once you're working with a team you have
to include a section called team
contributions and this is going to list
every member of your team and what they
did on the assignment
so hopefully every member of your team
is in agreement
about who did what by the time you turn
in your assignment
you don't have to do this for assignment
one because assignment one is going to
be done on your own
uh but for assignments two through four
you have to list what every member of
the team who every member of the team is
and how they contributed to the
assignment
we're asking you to put an
acknowledgement section that's going to
list the people that you discuss the
assignment with and you got help from
so aside from keeping you honest this is
also just the polite thing to do
right you want to acknowledge the people
who you got help from so list every
person that you talk to
and the concept that they help with and
this includes course staff if you talk
to core staff or
people on chat or so on and then finally
there's going to be a section that we
asked for called citations
uh and this is for citing sources that
you used so for anything that you need
to look up
we're asking you to document where you
looked it up
so the policy that we're adopting in
this course is something that professor
ethan miller suggested
and it's that copying
but citing if you copy something but you
cite it
that's not considered academic
misconduct so
if you copy something from stack
overflow and you cite it
then you may get less credit for that
right
in fact if you copy everything you won't
get any credit for it and that's what
the course staff
is here to to decide you won't get any
credit for somebody else's code but
if you but but if you cite it then
that's not considered cheating
so we really don't want to nail you for
cheating
so you know cite your work and that's
the way to avoid running afoul of any
accusations of misconduct we don't want
to accuse you of misconduct and you
don't want to get accused of misconduct
so that's going to be the policy in this
course
and if you want to read this and
understand it in more detail everything
that i just said is on the course
overview page on the on the course
website
it's also going to be included in the
assignment description
in case you uh in case you need to
review it again
but hopefully the policy is pretty
straightforward
and then when we get to a little bit
closer to exams then we'll talk about
academic integrity on exams and so on
and i don't think i need to talk about
that right now
like i said this is my least favorite
topic um
i really hate that this is an issue
and i think most of you also hate that
this is an issue and you would rather
not be spending time on this
unfortunately we have to i had a couple
of cases of academic integrity that i
had to pursue in this class
last year and i would really rather not
do that again so
make life easy for us make it so that i
don't have to do the thing that i hate
doing
and pursue these violations of academic
integrity by just citing everything that
that you use anything that you have to
look up document where you looked it up
anybody that you talk to say who you
talk to if you do that you'll be in good
shape
all right with that over with i'm going
to talk about something that's
much much much more pleasant so
i want to share with you uh so
my uh my research group here at uc santa
cruz is called the languages systems and
data lab or the lsd lab for short
we have a website it is lsda.ucsc.edu
and this is our website so
i'm sharing this with you because if you
want to know anything about my research
or or um
what i do you can find my my webpage
linked from here and you can also find
uh the stuff that my colleagues do so
the languages systems and data lab is
not just me
it's a collection of students and
faculty who are working in the areas of
programming languages
systems and databases and the
intersection of those research
traditions
so if that sounds interesting to you
then i urge you to go
check out our website and see what we're
up to and in particular i want to point
you to
the languages systems and data seminar
so
this is a weekly meeting where we meet
to discuss
interesting topics in the areas of
programming languages systems and
databases
and topics related to that so
uh bridging into formal methods and
verification and security
and beyond so the goal of this seminar
is to encourage interactions and
discussions between people in these
areas
we have a lot of external as well as
internal speakers
and you can get course credit for it
so there's a two credit course we meet
every friday at noon
for an hour and 15 minutes uh and if
you're interested
you should let me know because this is a
it's an easy way to get to pass fail
credits
and it's fun it also another thing about
the
these meetings is that we always start
with 15 minutes of social time
so you'll get a chance to uh to talk
with
um students and faculty and especially
grads
grad students who are in the lsd lab
and um and learn about who they are and
what they do
and you wouldn't if you're an undergrad
you won't be the only undergrad there
uh we have a lot of undergrads who who
join us and we'd love to have more
so in particular um the next talk on our
schedule
is going to be aldrin montana who's a
grad student that works with peter
alvaro and he's going to be speaking on
friday
if this sounds like fun to you then then
let me know
and i'll make sure that you get the
information
we also have a mailing list that you can
request to join
um and this by the way is open to
anybody in the world so you don't have
to be an enrolled
ucsc student in order to attend these
talks
so if you're not a student you can join
this mailing list called ucsc
lsd seminar announced and this is for
anyone in the world if you
sign up for that mailing list you'll get
the talk invitations
for people who are at ucsc we have an
internal mailing list as well
so if you're interested please check
that out we would love to see you there
it's lots of fun and if you register for
the course credit it's a very
kind of low effort way to get a couple
of credits you really don't have to do
anything other than attend the talks
all right i have another thing to
discuss let's see
in the five minutes that we have left
and this is something that i'm
if possible even more excited about so i
happen to be the organizer
of a conference of lightning talks
about the joy excitement and surprise of
computing this is called
uh bang bang khan so we we pronounce the
name of this conference bang bang khan
it's written with two exclamation points
and as you see i'm wearing my bang bang
con shirt today
so bang bang khan is a conference that
consists exclusively of lightning talks
that are 10 minutes long about
any computing related topic that brings
people to light and joy
and it's happening this may
the week of may 15-22 and our call for
talk proposals is open
so if you think that you might like to
give a 10-minute talk
about any computing-related topic that
brings you joy then go to
bangbangcon.com
and i will also share this link uh in
chat
and look at our call for talk proposals
so the call for proposals is open now
for another week
um it's open until april 8th and
you can submit a talk proposal about
literally any computing topic that
is interesting and our requirement is
that there has to be at least one
exclamation point in the title of your
talk
so if you look a little bit like what
we've done historically
it's been all over the map so there have
been
talks about games there have been talks
about
uh kind of classic uh like retro
computing
uh there have been talks about
interesting mathematical concepts that
intersect
with computing there have been uh
computational art
projects um it's awesome so
when you go to this website you can also
see all of our past talk recordings
we've been doing this
this is the eighth year that we've been
doing this uh so we have a lot of past
talks i'll just go to 2020 so you can
get an idea of um
like some of the titles of talks that
people have given in the past
notice that all of them have an
exclamation point in their name
so this is what we do right we ask
people to come and talk for 10 minutes
about anything that brings them to light
that has to do with computing
and i think it's incredibly fun so i'm
sharing this with you because
for one thing i think that some of you
might have talk proposals
that that you should submit and if so
then you know spend a little time
thinking about it
and look at our call for proposals
the other reason i'm sharing it with you
is because i hope that you'll attend
so this is going to be a pay what you
want conference
meaning that we're going to have a
suggested donation but
you can also attend for free if you want
to so there's not going to be any
sort of expensive registration fee
instead
you can pay whatever you afford
including nothing so it should be
accessible to students and everyone
and it's going to be happening in
mid-may so i'll advertise when the
when registration opens up that hasn't
happened yet because we're still at the
point of
collecting talk proposals and and
selecting a program
but i hope that some of you will
consider
applying or attending
all right that's it for today
and the first assignment is going to be
posted tomorrow
so if you have questions about the first
assignment after it comes out i hope
you'll be asking them on zulip
also sections are happening on monday
and sections are a great place to go
if you have questions about the homework
see you next week